hi I'm Erik Bosse and the ventures
endgame is still fresh on our minds
because three hours ain't enough we want
to know the three thousand hours of
movie that they left out of the final
cuts deleted scenes rejected concepts
sneakily netted trailer shots the
avengers endgame that could have been
and hey now that we're in an MCU
multiverse with infinite parallel
timelines maybe someday a story that
will be let us go back through avengers
endgame to break down all of these
deleted alternate storylines
it's where the one in the kids you don't
want to know starting with the opening
scene with hawkeye the moment up the
snap the screenwriters went back and
forth on win exactly to set the snap
early on there was actually an idea to
put the snap at the beginning of endgame
but instead they decided that they
wanted to leave infinity war with this
huge cliffhanger and killing Thanos in
the opening minutes of endgame followed
by a five-year time jump would plunge
the rock bottom that we were feeling
even lower as for Hawkeye they also
considered putting this Barton farm
scene in the snap montage at the end of
infinity war the screenwriters said that
they intended the Barton farm is the
first indication that the snap had a
wider effect but they removed it from
Infinity Ward because Hawkeye wouldn't
been in the movie prior to that moment
so it would have had less of an
emotional effect
Captain Marvel rescues Tony Stark and
nebula but endgame actually removed the
post-credits scene that we saw after
Captain Marvel that showed her meeting
Kat Natasha Brody and banner in Avengers
HQ presumably there was a longer version
of that scene that explained how Carole
could have tracked down the Benatar
perhaps through some coordinates
obtained from rocket the title of this
movie and game was actually different
before they said it was for a long time
going to be Infinity Gauntlet the title
of the Marvel Comics series that this
story is taken from the directors also
said that when they promoted the movie
in Korea the Koreans told them that the
Korean translation of dr. Strange's line
and infinity war we're in the endgame
now turned it into no hope so that made
them wonder about the title of the
second movie beam Avengers no hope after
the time jump cap runs the support group
but an early drafts cap was going to be
seen
living with Sharon Carter Peggy Carter's
great niece whom cap had a fling with in
Civil War the screenwriters said that
their relationship wasn't going very
well maybe because Sharon Carter is her
own woman and she thought it was kind of
weird how cap just kept putting brown
wigs on her and telling her to speak in
a British accent ultimately they removed
Sharon from the story because we could
just assume that all of the
characters have moved on to new lives
after these five years they said that
they always intended on this film ending
with cap getting his dance with Peggy so
they just figured that Peggy could be
caps North Star on his journey of
enlightened self-interest also deleted
from in-game war additional shots of
Natasha blowing off steam around
Avengers HQ many of which we saw in the
trailers like firing at a target range
sitting in the rain has one does when
they're super depressed another clip
online showed her with a punching bag
also there was a little Easter egg an
end game that showed Natasha's ballet
shoes hanging from a chair suggesting
that there might have been some footage
of her continuing her ballet from her
early KGB training Scott Lang returns he
visits a memorial apparently there was
an idea for similar memorials to be
shown in every major city around the
world who suggests the scale of billions
of people having been wiped out The
Avengers reassemble including that Thor
and smart Hulk both of which had been
carefully digitally removed from any
trailer footage the writers said that
they originally considered to move smart
Hulk to the first movie like during the
Wakanda battle the moment when Banner
and Hulk are arguing inside the
Hulkbuster armor that was going to end
with a compromise between them and their
consciousness is merging but if you
think about it that would have felt like
a victory moment and an ending that
needed to be a very bleak defeat like
Bruce Hulk would be like hey look guys
I'm big and green that's still smart why
is everyone crying so instead they've
revealed smart Hulk in endgame and they
did write scenes of banner gene-splicing
in lab but ultimately they decided that
the sudden reveal of him eating pancakes
in a diner would work just fine until
one of those kids looked directly into
the camera could have deleted that
moving on to the time heist which had
the most alternate iterations like
instead of spending the bulk of the
second act to the Battle of New York in
2012 originaly much of it was going to
be set in Asgard when the ether and a
tesseract were both present at one point
Cuzzi tesseract was in Odin's vault
there was a version of this movie where
Tony Stark was going to be here sneaking
around Asgard in a stealth suit fighting
Heimdall the only one who could see him
now it is worth remembering that Markus
and McFeely wrote the script for Thor
the dark world so it's probably one of
the settings that they felt more
comfortable meddling with apparently in
Asgard there was also an idea to have
fat Thor fight his buffer 2013 self but
that cat versus cat fight already paid
that off in another way the
screenwriters also described a different
trip back in time to the Triskelion to
get the tesseract and
another story featuring a road trip to
dr. Strange's house with a Joe Russo
walked in said let's just revisit the
Battle of New York when there were three
stones in the same place at the same
time it kind of mirrored that aha moment
between start Natasha and Hulk in the
movie Russo's also confirmed a rejected
concept for the Avengers revisiting the
collectors vaults and nowhere and
guardians of the galaxy in 2014 when
both the Power Stone and the ether were
both briefly there the Guardians brought
the power stone there and Lady SIF
brought the ether there at the end of
Thor of the dark world they said that
during this revisiting sequence Captain
Marvel was going to join the group
really if you think about it nowhere in
the Battle of New York could have been
the two main mission destinations along
with war Mir but the rooster said that
we already saw a lot of the collectors
vault an indigenous infinity war and
they didn't want to have to revisit
another infinity war setting on top of
war Mir as for the trip to Morag the
filmmaker said it was originally going
to be underwater since the planet Morag
used to be covered in vast oceans but
that proved to be over complicated
production wise and then finally war
mere originally Hawkeye was going to
sacrifice himself but the screenwriter
said that gen underdahl the visual
effects producer read that outline and
she said don't you take this away from
Natasha so ultimately they had Clint in
etosha wrestle over who gets to do it
Natasha ultimately made the sacrifice
also the Russo brothers describe a
sequence in which they noses forces were
going to show up on Boromir and attack
them Natasha would have had to take the
gauntlet and run with it over the bore
mere cliff okay moving on to the final
battle now many of these great surprises
were digitally altered and trailer
footage like cap shields being shattered
and giant man actually being behind war
machine abroad kidding that side also
Sean Gunn posted that Krag Len from
guardians of the galaxy was going to
play a bigger role in this battle with
yondu's yaki Arrowhead piece in general
the writers said that this battle was
written to be much longer with its own
three-act structure including a trench
scene where the avengers took a break
from the battle for around three minutes
to regroup and re-strategize the writer
said that this broke up the pacing too
much didn't play well the filmmakers
said that originally more of the final
battle was spent on character reunions
like a reunion between Scott Lang and
hope Van Dyne which would have been a
little weird because Scott Lang was only
missing for what felt like him for five
hours and hope and I'm dusted and didn't
really experience five years of missing
anyone they also said the resumed
between rocket and Groot but they want
to save that interaction
a future movie but they did include a
brief shot of rocket shields and groots
during the barrage there was also a
behind-the-scenes shot showing the
reunion between Stark and Peter that was
actually a bit longer Peter was gonna
make a joke about his gray hairs and
Stark would have kissed him on the cheek
Scarlet Witch returns in the battle and
the writers said that they actually
considered adapting the events of the
House of M comics that was a storyline
in which Scarlet Witch manipulated
reality to try to bring back her lost
children but she created an alternate
earth controlled by mutants in which
humans known as sapiens here were
relegated to second-class citizens and a
beaters the Marvel heroes having to
reset reality but ultimately they
decided that should be saved for a
future film as well and then finally the
ending the Russos revealed that at the
moment of Tony Stark's snapped he was
going to be transported to the
orange-tinted Soul realm that they nos
visited infinity war and that sterk was
going to see a vision of his daughter
Morgan but grown up a little played by
Kathryn Langford she was going to give
Tony peace to let go I actually explored
more of this in my breakdown of the end
game ultimate ending so which of these
alternate scenes would you have most
preferred to see the most in Avengers
in-game comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at da vas and subscribe to new
rockstars on YouTube and subscribe to
our podcast feed inside marble thank you
for joining me and again you really
should have taken out that direct eye
contact shot it just feels unnerving
and to hunting